y hay temor en eeuu ante una posible
recesión económica porque qué está
sucediendo allí ya hemos hablado de la
alta inflación que se está presentando y
el aumento en las tasas de interés pero
lo explica mejor jorge hurtado que está
aquí en el estudio jorge adelante bueno
el presidente bailén dijo hoy que una
recesión no es inevitable en ese país en
una conversación que tuvo con la agencia
associated press dijo que el pueblo
estadounidense está muy muy deprimido
después de dos años de pandemia la
volatilidad de la economía y ahora el
aumento de los precios de la gasolina
allí los hogares estadounidenses que ven
cómo se reducen sus fondos de jubilación
al tiempo que aumentan cada mes sus
facturas de alimentación y de servicios
públicos algo que tiene la popularidad
de bailén en su nivel más bajo sólo 39
por ciento de los adultos
estadounidenses aprueban la actuación de
bailén como presidente una
desaceleración a principios de 2024 no
estaba en el radar pero ahora es una
probabilidad de tres de cuatro puntos
según las últimas estimaciones de
bloomberg economics en mayo de la
inflación anual en ese país registró 8,6
por ciento la más alta en 40 años y
obligó al banco central de eeuu a sufrir
de forma agresiva los tipos es algo que
la práctica significa desacelerar la
economía para tratar de controlar la
inflación porque hay un escenario
similar estaba viendo argentinas también
anunciaron un aumento en las tasas de
interés de referencia en este país
suramericano
las tasas allí pasaron del 49 por ciento
del 52% en el rendimiento anual en lo
que supone la sexta subida de los tipos
de interés en lo que va de este año la
autoridad monetaria argentina y luego
los mínimos de las tasas de interés
sobre los plazos fijos para personas
físicas la tasa mínima será ahora del 53
por ciento anual estos incremento de
cinco puntos porcentuales para las
imposiciones a 30 días mientras que para
el resto de depositantes se va a situar
en el 50 por ciento un aumento de cuatro
puntos porcentuales este incremento está
contemplado en el programa económico
consensuado entre el gobierno argentino
y el fondo monetario internacional
argentina registró en mayo una inflación
anual del 60,7 por ciento la más alta en
30 años a propósito de las protestas que
comentabas anteriormente que los vemos
en diferentes ciudades de ese país
hablemos ahora de perú porque un país
que produce tanta cantidad de comida y
tiene cultivos de todo tipo puede estar
al borde de una hambre santiago y es que
la organización de naciones unidas para
la alimentación y la agricultura fao
advirtió que el 51% de la población
peruana está en riesgo de enfrentar una
crisis de seguridad alimentaria según el
reporte 1 de cada 4 peruanos puede
cubrir la canasta básica de alimentos
nuestro corresponsal en perú francisco
zacarías recorrió algunas zonas de
pobreza en ese país y nos trae la
siguiente historia
marina ramírez es desempleada y madre
soltera la falta de recursos le ha
llevado a valerse de ayudas sociales
como la olla común para alimentar a sus
cuatro hijos una que todo porque todo
está caro y porque no alcanza porque a
veces no hay trabajo toda su vida toda
su vida y no hay trabajo por las
circunstancias del gobierno es lo que
está mal en lo que vivimos en perú más
de 8 millones de personas viven en
situación de pobreza y más de un millón
son pobres extremos según el instituto
nacional de estadística-
4000 ollas comunes creadas por mujeres
son el único paliativo que tienen los
más necesitados para alimentarse en
estos momentos sin embargo están en
riesgo de cerrar porque no reciben
recursos ante la crisis el gobierno
evalúa entregar un bono de más de 324
millones de dólares medida que es
criticada por diversos economistas lo
que debería hacer el gobierno más bien
es ayudar a las áreas comunes abastecer
con productos a las ollas comunes cosas
que hasta el momento no ha hecho o sea
olímpicamente hay 2600 hoy comunes que
están
abandonadas que no tienen atención
sistemática por parte del gobierno
porfa esteban vive un doble drama además
de batallar para que la olla común que
dirige no cierre por falta de alimentos
también tiene que luchar por sanar a su
hijo que forma parte del 38% de los
niños peruanos que sufren de anemia me
siento triste por lo que mi niño me está
así bajo peso y allí es también igual
que están igual bueno y son más más
chiquitos también me voy a común así
como marina y orf a otros 15 millones de
peruanos no pueden comer tres veces al
día también un 11.5 por ciento de niñas
y niños menores de 5 años están en
situación de desnutrición crónica
pero no se escapa la crisis alimentaria
mundial que ya está afectando a toda
latinoamérica
el informe de francisco zacarías desde
perú muchas gracias jorge punto final en
la economía a continuación del debate